veterinarian Walter Silva Combs long
stretches of beach every day searching
for sea lions suspected of being
infected with avian flu
this young female died most likely
because of the virus she could not swim
not only because of respiratory problems
but its effects on the central nervous
system
since January Silva and other
researchers have been taking samples to
determine if more than 700 sea lions
have died of the virus
many of the Dead have washed ashore
along Peru's Coast
others like this one lie helpless
experts say they live in colonies many
in protected areas infecting each other
it's the first time the verse attacks
this way we had not seen a case like
this the wildlife being affected in such
large quantities
here in the beach we sort of fukusana
soila Rodriguez says she's worried
because the sea lions are dying near
bathers
is horrible it's full of flies and they
cough day and night
Nature has spared some species from
being infected but others are being
decimated more than 60 000 wild birds
have died since the virus was detected
in November in Peru more than 200
million birds have died or called around
the world since 2021 because of the
avian flu researchers here say they're
afraid the virus has mutated and can now
infect from mammal to mammal and rapidly
expand into people's homes
ten-year-old lady is being tested for a
cuff her owner Marcia Sanchez blames the
sea lions ill on the platforms of this
series sort I think we're sitting on a
time bomb with so many animals ill and
we're also mammals who knows if we can
also get sick
the national forestry and Wildlife
service says more than one hundred
thousand sea lions are at risk many
survive but there's no cure and many
infected are likely to die and unable to
say what is the real danger for humans
they advise people to stay away Mariana
Sanchez Lima